le projet sirène est un projet qui
cherche une autre façon de collecter
d'hydrocarbures à travers
poils et poils d'animaux
ceci cela a certaines propriétés qui
permet l'absorption de
hydrocarbures et repousse l'eau car le
les cheveux sont
[Musique]
hydrophobe ben ben j'ai rien vu
projet initiative Instagram
sirène Et ça me semble vraiment être quelque chose
super et bien si c'est pour
moins un grain de sable ou des cheveux pour
sauve le lac, crois-moi, avec la douleur
Qu'est-ce que cela m'apporte ?Je suis prêt à tout donner.
tous mes
barbe oui, je l'ai été plusieurs fois
Maracayo, je connais le lac La Vereda et
C'est vraiment un très bel endroit pour
ça n'a pas le plaisir des touristes
à cause de l'odeur à cause du bois de chauffage Et si cela peut
Ça ne me coûte rien d'aider
de moi
[Musique]
chiot
Yo